Speaker 1: We don't yet know exactly what
will happen today when it comes to the swearing
in of lying Republican Congressman elect George
Santos.
But it is now not only US criminal investigation
that Santos is under, having now found out
where he is, Brazil has restarted its criminal
investigation of the very same Jorge Santos.
This is unbelievable.
The new or not unbelievable as we've learned
about this guy.
The New York Times reports Brazilian authorities
will revive a fraud case against Jorge Santos.
A 2008 court case had been suspended because
Brazilian law enforcement couldn't find Santos.
When he takes his seat, he will do so under
the shadow of active investigations by federal
and local prosecutors.
But an older criminal case may be more pressing.
This stems from a 2008 incident involving
a stolen checkbook, just like a pedestrian
alleged criminal is this guy and the case
had been suspended for the better part of
a decade, writes The New York Times, because
the police couldn't find him.
Spokeswoman for the Rio prosecutor's office
said that with Santos, his whereabouts identified
a formal request will be made to the DOJ to
notify him of the charges a necessary step,
step after which the case will proceed with
or without him.
The criminal case in Brazil was first disclosed
to the New York Times in a New York Times
investigation that uncovered broad discrepancies
in his resume.
I love that term.
There were discrepancies.
What is it he is accused of doing in Brazil?
It's the following.
A month before his 20th birthday, Santos entered
a small clothing store in the Brazilian city
of Niteroi outside of Rio.
He spent nearly 700 bucks using a stolen checkbook
and a false name.
Court records show he admitted the fraud to
the shop owner in 2009, writing on Orkut,
a popular social media website in Brazil,
quote, I know I screwed up, but I want to
pay.
In 2010, he and his mother told the police
he used the stolen checkbook of a man his
mother used to work for and made fraudulent
purchases.
So this this is just a horrible, horrible
person.
And we don't exactly know what's going to
happen today, although he almost certainly
will be seated.
And you may even know about that by the time
today's show goes live.
But we now have a situation where the Brazilian
government conveniently knows exactly where
to find him.
This is what Kevin McCarthy gets or whoever.
Right, for refusing to expel this clown and
say, you know what?
Too much dishonesty, too concerning, too disturbing
what he did.
Now, Republicans are going to have to deal
with or stonewall and pretend it's not going
on.
What's going on with Jorge Santos?
And it is quite a humiliating cloud.
Now, will they care?
I don't know.
But we're talking about someone with outstanding
warrants in another country, essentially,
and under criminal investigation in the United
States.
If we want to be conspiratorial and we never
do, except sometimes we speculate.
Is it possible that Santos made a promise
to McCarthy in McCarthy's fight for the speakership,
which is as of this moment that I am recording
today, not a guarantee.
We will know more about that within hours.
Is it possible Santos promise to back McCarthy
if McCarthy promise not to try to get him
kicked out of Congress?
It's a question.
It's not an assertion that I believe that
happened.
But it is certainly a sensible question given
the circumstances.
We don't yet know whether Kevin McCarthy will
have all the votes he needs to be speaker.
And the question of loyalty between these
two afterwards seems very, very uncertain.
The other aspect to this is there are increasingly
questions about the large amounts of money
funneled through the Santos campaign that
suggested that he maybe had a source of funds.
That was unclear.
It didn't really line up with his fake claims
about where he used to work.
I don't know.
But once we now know.
Although.
This is petty in a sense.
He was 19 years old in Brazil, talking about
$700.
He clearly is willing to get up to some high
jinks.
And if he was willing to do this at age 19,
what is it he may have been willing to do
over the last year or two with regard to the
$700,000?
That now is a question mark in terms of the
donation he made to his own campaign.
A couple people e-mailed me and said, what
about extradition?
Is it possible the U.S. would extradite him
to Brazil?
I don't know.
I wasn't able to talk to any lawyers about
this.
We do have a treaty on extradition that has
been ratified by the U.S. and Brazil, signed
in 1961, published in 1964.
And I don't know how plausible it really is
to think Santos might be extradited to Brazil,
but this is the epitome of the Republican
Party in 2023, grifters, alleged criminals
and people who are going to spend the next
two years starting today trying to impeach
Joe Biden, trying to investigate Hunter Biden.
It starts today.
And we we'd really better be ready to know
how to deal with it.
It's not clear to me that the Democratic Party
is actually prepared.